Do you?...Alright
*bong bing* oh no.
Hi my name is Grace Helbig, and if you didn't know, now you know and your life is different now!
Brooks and I made an attempt to review
Grammy's fashion last night, but we were...
not in the right state of mind...
Squeeze together
Brooks: I'm with you Grace: *burps* Brooks: oh yeah, my name's Brooks if you didn't know that you
know it now.
Okay...ummm
Oh God. We have been watching WWE Royal Rumble
and just been too excited and also Brooks got hives.
But we're here now and we're doing it live! On tape, and then
edited, and then uploaded, and all very prepared.
Let's get into some Grammy fashion reviews...
reviewing. Perfect! Alessia Cara. This is great!
You look like a recently divorced dad going out for the first time.
An older brother at his younger sister's wedding
that won't go full suit but'll make an attempt.
I love it. Cute! Julia Michaels. Wow!
This is like a very punk Cinderella. Like you're
Cinderella but your fairy godmother's like Kat Von D. Cute! Zayn.
Awwww. Why does Zayn always look like he's trying
to communicate pain, anguish, or just
confusion with his eyebrows. Looks like
he's watching an ex-lover walk away
for the first time. Cute! Miley Cyrus.
God, I just, I love Miley Cyrus
more and more and more and more. This new evolution of her,
I am a big fan of. She looks like a very
sensitive, romantic dominatrix, and I love it. Cute!
Pink. Wow! I love Pink, and this looks like Snuffleupagus
was going to an EDM concert and it took all the ecstasy
and it, you know what, had a great time. Cute!
Heidi Klum. There she is, she made it. Our girl
made the Grammys. I feel relieved.
This is very, like, Victoria's Secret
Granny Goth. Cute! Cardi B. Oh my god.
I love Cardi B. so much, and I love everything about this.
You know that movie Donnie Darko, when like the
time space continuum, like,
bubble,
like chemtrails come out of his body?
This kind of looks like that, in a dress form. And, you know what?
It's perfect. This is very Bjork swan dress meets
80s bridal fashion, and I love it.
Cute! Katie Holmes. What are you doing there, and how
is what? Alright! This is very sexy and cool
and interesting, and kind of looks like when, you know,
seniors in high school make their prom dresses out of duct tape.
Cute! Chrissy Teigen. God,
another human I just love, and you're making
another human inside of your cool human body already?
Like, nature rules when that happens. Like, if I looked back
at a photo of my mom, and like, this is the photo that
I saw, I'd be like,
The *bleep* am I supposed to do with my life? Rita Ora. This
is beautiful! Your body looks amazing! I
like all the swoosh and the swoops, and all of it! This looks like when I
try and, like, erase things in photoshop, but I don't do it
correctly, and I just kind of
you know, like that. Cute!
Camila Cabello! I feel very 80s vibe from all of these
gowns and outfits. You got a little disco ball, tamagotchi,
purse thing happening? Cute! And ruching,
in a new spot that I didn't know ruching could be in.
Ruching is like when the fabric bunches, so it helps
make like your mid section
look slimmer, but she's going for ruching on the...the
hip joints. Get it girl! Slim out them thigh sockets! Cute!
Hailee Steinfeld (pronounces Steinfeld many different ways)
The fu...what is this? You look like a 2018
tube of Crest toothpaste! It's like your top half is very classic,
and then your
bottom half is like black mirroring through a curtain and coming out from the future. Cute!
Kelly Clarkson. *gasps* Oh!
Gothic Renaissance, 'scuse you! Is this what The Handmaid's Tale
is? I haven't read or watched it, but I assume it's like...this?
But bonnets. Cute! Kesha. You look like a business
cowboy that likes to party! And I love it!
Clint Eastwood meets John Travolta meets
Barbie. Nothin' wrong with that! Except maybe...some stuff,
but, outfit wise, cute! Sam Smith.
Where did you go? You look great, good for you!
A green suit?!
How dare you. Cute! Donald Glover. Aw, Dang it.
I don't like her, I glove her. I hate myself.
But cute! Anna Kendrick. *gasps* What sexy,
fancy, future 80s law firm does everyone work at?!
How do I get an interview? This is like Sex and the City meets Wolf of
Wall Street meets, like,
kind of the Monopoly man? Regardless, cute! Janelle Monáe.
My...this is, might be my favorite look
of the whole night. I love Janelle Monáe,
and this, just, is so good. It's like you're a butler
in Narnia, and I love everything about it. Cute!
Lana Del Ray. It's like a walking Snapchat slash
Urban Outfitters campaign ad. Cute!
Lady Gaga. Look, you did it. You did it,
and you did it. You look like a Madam of the coolest brothel
ever. Beautiful, chic, regal, cumbersome,
high fashion. And the back of your head looks like a cool sneaker
on someone with cankles. You doin' it,
ya nailin' it, good job. Cute!
Okay, that's it for my Grammys fashion review. I hope you guys enjoyed this video,
if you did, make sure to subscribe to this youtube channel. I'm making videos
Tuesdays and Thursdays, technically, but this doesn't...
make that seem true. Also, click that bell notification so you know when I
upload, because it clearly is...
all over the place. If you liked this video, give it a thumbs up. Let me know in the comments down below
who you loved at the Grammys. Obviously, I missed a ton of
really well dressed, beautiful people, that are very talented,
doing cool, interesting, fun things. So let me know! Other
than that, I don't know.
Jaden Smith. Yeah, you did it. This is like very
floor of the workroom in Project Runway chic
meets like, stepdad shoes. Cute!